willkommen beim neuen video ich hab mir
gedacht geht es mal wieder hierhin
allerdings ist mir aufgefallen der
hintergrund passt gar nicht nicht mein
haben wir noch weihnachten haben wir
nicht deswegen was machen wir jetzt
das war ganz eng jedoch in die scheiße
aus kann hier aber auch nicht alles
umbauen weil eigentlich soll ist das
wohnzimmer meiner eltern meckern
bestimmt egal was sie letztlich bekommen
habe bis dieser congratulations zu
100.000 soeben das muss ich mir noch
einfach dass ihr könnt ihr mal ideen in
die kommentare schreiben
wie ich ihr dann immer um bevor ich halt
ein video drehen auf jeden fall habe ich
mich heute überleg dir fragt michael
joecks hast du eine freundin und da
dachte ich mir kommen mache ich kein
großes geheimnis um eine freundin hab
ich jetzt aktuell nicht allerdings habe
ich mir gedacht ja kommt so boyfriend
golf fan videos auf you tube bikini
einer krassen deswegen habe ich mit alex
wenn du dir eine freundin suchst dann
soll es auf jeden fall eine youtube drin
sein
mit der ich dann videos drehen kann
klicks generieren kann und daraus geld
für mich raus springt versteht ihr so
dass er wie schon andere youtuber
gemacht und zwar gibt es so ein quiz
oder so eine auswahl dingsbums da muss
man als saft ausgeht
und dann wird dir deine youtube freundin
vorgeschlagen und die schreibe ich dann
an claire mir die und dreh mit werkteile
videos so mache ich das let's go so
leute wie man hier sehen kann kann ich
hier ermitteln welche youtube passt zu
dir
ich finde das jetzt heraus und wir
starten einfach mal
ich hoffe es kommt auch wirklich eine
raus die schon für e mails mit der man
gute videos drehen kann und wieder noch
klicks bekommen die wirklich auf youtube
super was schaust du am liebsten
letztlich also ich schon gern blogs auf
jeden fall weil ich das ist finde ich
das ist kreativ interaktiv keine ahnung
also ich gucke eigentlich auf youtube
fast nur blogs zurzeit ohne scheiß was
ist hier bei einer frau wichtig dass
hier hört ist wie ich es bin ich will ja
mit ihr gute videos drehen die auf
klicks bekommen hab ja schon gesagt
deswegen nehme ich hier ganz klar ihr
aussehen wer einige von euch verstehen
gerade nicht dass das nicht so gemeint
ist also wenn ich in den kommentaren
oberflächlich lese gut egal ich sage
nicht mehr welche youtuber schaust du
gerne was zieht dann soja elf leute
macht natürlich seine clique janko kommt
natürlich richtig gut an
julian co neben war welche haarfarbe
gefällt ihr bei mädchen also ich würde
sagen für youtube das zieht ist wirklich
blond gut blond ist immer gut das zieht
so ich wäre natürlich für blonde geld
wie viel zeit verbringst du am tag im
internet jahren schon etwas eins bis
fünf stunden eins bis fünf stunden eine
bis fünf stunden ja das kreuz machen wie
groß sollte deine traumfrau sein also
ich würde sagen größer als ich sollte
ihn das steht so groß wie ich wäre gut
sie soll kleiner als ich sein also
entweder so groß wie ich wäre gut oder
sie soll klein als ich sei nicht wird er
sagen sie seien kleiner als ich ein
bisschen wenn du wenn du deinen ganzen
leben nur noch einen youtube schauen
dürfte es welcher wäre das
new dawn ist cool den mag ich könnte wie
feierlich aber lustig nimmt wenn tv
welchen dieser weiblichen superhelden
magst du am liebsten das ist mir etwas
unangenehm aber ich weiß überhaupt nicht
wie die aussehen keine ahnung ich kenne
batman kenne ich super sein kann ich
auch captain marvel halb school
annehmbar wenn du einen youtuber wärst
was würdest du machen
ich hätte keine festen formate ganz
viele formate hettich displays und
kommentare
ich nehme ganz viele blogs und die
letzte frage was hältst du von youtube
deutschland nicht viel ich liebe es wie
es ist also ich halte jetzt nicht wenig
davon
ich liebe es aber auch nicht wie es ist
deswegen ist es mir eigentlich
scheißegal ich mache mein ding
fertig oder nicht okay leute ich kann
das jetzt auswerten bin ohne scheiß voll
gespannt weil ich meine das wird ja dann
meine freundin die muss ich ja dann auch
ertragen so ich hoffe es kommt irgendwas
gutes raus mit der man auch bald
anfangen kann
irgendwie war es klar oder welche
youtube passt zu dir zu 60 prozent sind
ich will doch 100% zu 60 prozent sind
sie du passt eindeutig zu lieben kibi
die seite hat aber ganz schnell raus ob
du es glaubst oder nicht etwas besser
als laien tivi und sie zusammen
ich hoffe ihr werdet glücklich so da
geht dann schreibe ich dich jetzt mal
bei instagram an
vielleicht liest du es hier in spa
direkt hier
foto versenden ja noch ein game filter
auf war das sieht gut aus oder guckt
euch das mal ich finde das kann man auf
jeden fall nehmen dann können wir uns
treffen
ich hab das ist ehrlich gesagt scheiße
egal das wird sie nicht lesen wenn sie
das lesen wird dann habe ich ein kleines
problem ja heute das war's mit diesem
video wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lasst auf jeden fall jetzt genau an
dieser stelle daumen nach oben da ich
hoffe die dagegen meldet sich bei mir
und wir können mal zusammen im video
drehen
es stimmt ansonsten stopp jetzt auf
keinen fall weg scheint nächste woche
kommen drei videos die woche ganz normal
sonntag um 18 uhr das video und
irgendwie in der woche kommen jetzt
immer videos irgendwann am besten also
meistens immer abends denke ich dann hab
ich immer zeit wirklich auch zwei
rauszuhauen also dann kann ich am tag
noch schneiden dienstags mittwochs
donnerstags keine ahnung check auf jeden
fall snapshot und instagram bei mir ab
dass auf jeden fall mitteilen
aber nicht vergessen und das was einst
von instagram als eingeblendet hier um
links geht es doch weiter mit meinem
netz - könnt ihr auch auf jeden fall mal
vorbeischauen ist cool und hat drei
leute